[Applause]
We made peace a symbol of us in the name
of peace. Peace. We gather here now. Oh
Lord, please make these days of ours on
this earth filled with peace.
Peace team, the solution for humanity.
Glorious.
[Music]
Asalamu alaykum.
I welcome all of you to this exclusive
program TV talk shows and analysis. I
Dr. Muhammad Naik am your host and
moderator for this program. We have with
us Dr. Zakir Nikk. Dr. Dr. Zakir Abdul
Karim Naik, president of the Islamic
Research Foundation is renowned as a
dynamic international aator on Islam and
comparative religion. Dr. Zakir is
famous for his critical analysis to
challenging questions posed by audiences
after his public talks. In the last 13
years, he has delivered over 1300 public
talks worldwide. He has successfully
participated in dialogues and debates
with prominent personalities of other
faiths. His public dialogue with Dr.
William Campbell of USA in Chicago on
April 1st, 2000 was a resounding success
in presenting the compatibility of Quran
with established science.
his interfaith dialogue with the famous
Indian guru CC Ravi Shankar on the topic
the concept of God in Hinduism and Islam
in the light of sacred scriptures held
in Bangalore on 21st January 2006 was
very well appreciated for propounding
the oneness of God Almighty. The Indian
Express included Dr. Zakir Nike in its
list of the 100 most powerful Indians in
2009 as well as in 2010 amongst the
billion plus population of India. He was
ranked at the third most powerful
spiritual guru after Sri Si Ravish
Shankar and Baba Ramdev in 2009 and this
year in 2010 he superseded them too. Dr.
Zakir appears regularly on many
international TV channels throughout the
world. He is the spirit and brain behind
peace TV which is watched worldwide by
over 100 million viewers. Dr. Zakir Nikk
stood out most eloquently for Islam and
Muslims
in his TV talk show Walk the Talk
conducted by Shaker Gupta, editor and
chief of Indian express on the NDTV
program walk the talk
aired on 7th and 8th of March 2009. Dr.
Zakir Nikk appears regularly on many
international TV channels in over 200
countries worldwide.
Hundreds of his talks, dialogues and
debates are available on WCDs and DVDs.
He has authored books on Islam and
comparative religion. Peace TV, his
brainchild, has become one of his most
impactful, unmititigated and
far-reaching phenomena worldwide in
creating a better awareness of Islam and
removing misconceptions about Islam. The
everinccreasing over 100 million
viewers, avid viewers of Peace TV, are
evolving into mass defenders of the
true, just and peaceful Islamic message
for humanity at large and challenging
the negative stereotyping of Islam and
Muslims worldwide by some powerful
corporate media, anti-Islamic
governments, and vested interests. As
far as our topic for today goes, TV talk
shows. A dictionary meaning of a TV talk
show is a program during which
well-known people discuss a topic or
answer questions asked or telephoned in
by the audience.
We start today's program
by asking our guest tonight Dr. Zakir
Nike directly about the differences of
these various talks and the formats
they tend to follow.
Welcome to our show Dr.
Zakirum.
It's my pleasure.
Our audience here and all over who
respect you so much would first of all
like to be clear on this concept. What
is the difference between a TV
interview, a panel discussion, a TV talk
show and a TV talk?
Alhamdulillah.
As far as the difference is concerned
between a TV talk or a TV interview or a
panel discussion or a TV talk show is
that a TV talk is just a continuous talk
given by a speaker or a specialist or a
celebrity in front of a camera. He has
got no audience. He's directly facing
the camera and there's no interruption
whatsoever. As far as the TV interview
is concerned, it is an interview taken
by a host of a celebrity or a specialist
in that field. The host asks questions
to the celebrity or to the specialist
and replies to the queries or the
questions asked by the host. As far as
the panel discussion is concerned, there
are a few people on the panel maybe two,
three, four, five or many. All of them
may be specialist concerning the subject
in discussion or in the panel there may
be two groups. One may be opposing the
subject, one may be in favor of the
subject. This is a panel discussion and
there's a moderator and this moderator
sees to it that he gives equal
opportunity to all the panelist and he
gets the best out of the show. As far as
a TV talk show is concerned, it is
evolved recently in the past few decades
after the television media has expanded.
And in a TV talk show, it's a mixture.
In a TV talk show, it may be a host
interviewing the celebrity or the
specialist. And while in interviewing,
there may be a group of audience that is
listening live or he can throw the floor
open to the people to ask questions on
the phone line. If it's a live TV talk
show, there can be people who are asking
questions on the telephone or TV talk
show can be a panel discussion. There
can be a few people who are there on the
panel and the moderator he asks
questions to the panelist whether they
belong to the same view or they may
belong to opposing view and while he's
asking question to the panelist. There
may be a live audience which is
watching. They too can take part in that
TV talk show or the TV talk show can be
thrown open to the people if it's a live
TV talk show to the people who are
watching so that they can ask questions
on the telephone. So these are basically
the difference between a TV interview,
TV talk, a panel discussion and TV talk
shows.
Jakala for that uh basic clarification.
Do you personally prefer taking part in
a TV interview, a panel discussion, a TV
talk show, a TV talk or a public lecture
to present your viewpoint?
And why?
If you give me the option amongst all
six, the best I would like is a public
lecture and second I would like is a TV
talk. The reason is because in a public
lecture and in a TV talk there is no
interruption. I can present my view
without being interrupted because
normally if a host is there or if a
moderator is there there are chances
depending upon the moderator I may be
able to present my view I may not be
able to present my view depending upon
the intentions etc. I prefer a public
lecture and a TV talk as compared to the
other three four. If you had a choice to
take part in
a public lecture or a TV talk, which
would you prefer and why?
Compared to a public lecture and a TV
talk, but natural, I prefer a public
lecture because a public lecture
normally is in front of an audience. So,
but natural the impact of a speaker is
higher. Speaking in front of a camera
looks like a speaking in front of a
wall. So, I prefer personally speaking
in public giving a live lecture. But
natural duration is longer. It can be
maybe of half an hour or 1 hour or one
and a half hour. And that's much better
because in a public lecture normally I
stand. In a TV talk you have to sit
normally. So you can stand and also give
a TV talk. And in a public lecture it is
much more interesting because you get
the reaction of the audience. So when
you get the reaction of the audience the
impact and the presentation of a speaker
is better. And today's scientific
research tells us that when a person
gives a public speech or lecture, 93%
depends on his presentation skills and
7% is the matter. 7% of the marks of the
public lecture goes to the content to
the matter of what he speaks. 93% is the
presentation skills but natural which
involves body language which involves
modulation, gestures, eye to eye
contact. Because when a person speaks
even his eye is speaking, even his hand
is speaking. So I personally prefer a
public lecture in which a person can
present better. He can see the reaction
of an audience as compared to a TV talk
which is speaking in front of a camera.
Dr. Zakir, you have delivered over a
thousand public lectures worldwide. How
many TV talks have you delivered?
But natural the maximum that I've given
my life is public lectures. As far as TV
talks are concerned, maybe a few
hundred. I don't know the number, but it
will be few hundred. Maybe three 400 TV
talks I've given. Alhamdulillah.
Does that mean that you prefer giving
lectures and TV talks only and avoid
being questioned?
No. As far as being questioned, I prefer
the question answer better than the
public lecture. But being questioned by
interviewer and a moderator is different
by being questioned by the public. I
prefer being questioned by a questioner.
That's the reason whenever I give a
public talk, I prefer that the question
answer session is longer than the public
lecture because a public talk or a
public lecture is a monologue. It's a
one-way traffic. In a question answer
session, it's a two-way traffic. It's
much more interesting for the audience
as well as for me and it's challenging
for me that I don't know what question
the person going to ask. So, I prefer a
question answer session much better than
a TV talk. And that's the reason when we
handle question on session when the
program is organized by us or when I'm
called by the host I tell them I prefer
the question is asked live I don't
prefer chits because when someone gives
the chits you know there are chances if
you get maybe 30 40 100 questions you
can select what you want to answer and
then the audience may feel that you know
some questions ak has answered some he
hasn't answered so I normally prefer
that in a question answer session the
questioner lines up behind the
microphone and he asks the question live
so no one can say that I'm selecting
what I want to answer. So whoever is
first in the queue in the microphone he
is the person who gets the chance and I
personally prefer giving an opportunity
first to the non-Muslims then to the
Muslims because they have a better right
to know about Islam than the person who
already is a Muslim. So that is the
reason we prefer giving chance and
opportunity to the non-Muslims. And I
enjoy a question answer session much
more than the lecture.
How many TV interviews, panel
discussions or TV talk shows have you
taken part in and why?
As far as TV interviews are concerned,
that also may be a few hundred TV
interviews.
As far as
pal discussions are concerned, I don't
know the exact number, maybe 50. Same
with TV talk shows. I have attended many
TV talk shows which are live and I
always prefer attending a TV talk show
which is broadcast live which is
telecast live in which a person's view
cannot be edited. So I prefer attending
TV talk shows which are broadcast live
rather than which are recorded and
telecast later after a few days after a
few weeks. As far as panel discussions
are concerned
maybe 30 40 I don't know the exact
number but close to that.
Dr. Zakir, is it right as most people
presume that you prefer appearing only
on Muslim television channels? Yes, as
you asked me that what is the reason
that I prefer speaking on a talk show
and a public as compared to giving an
interview or having a panel discussion
where an interview is concerned normally
it also depends upon the intention and
the integrity of the person taking the
interview and that mostoever is
important in a panel discussion. The
moderator is very important because if
the intentions and the integrity of the
moderator I'm not correct then there are
high chances that the things you speak
can be moderated or it can be rather
misrepresented. So what I really say
that the difference between a TV talk
and a TV interview is that in a TV
interview the person asking your
question can ask you leading questions
which I've got no problem with but
sometimes they not give you a chance to
complete the answer but a TV interview
is far more safer than a panel
discussion and a TV talk show because in
a panel discussion since there are many
speakers who are there on the panel
maybe three four or more than that here
the intention
and the integrity
of the moderator as well as the producer
of the show is important because if the
moderator wants to promote a particular
viewpoint which he prefers, he can give
more chance to the panelist whose view
he agrees with and there are high
chances that he can cut short the answer
of the panelist who he doesn't agree
with. So therefore in a panel discussion
when the people are watching at home on
the television if they're not aware of
the media how the media works they may
not know what goes behind the scene. So
the moderator can sway the panel
discussion and secondly it's also
important the view the integrity and the
intention of the producer of the show
because if the intention of the producer
of the show is not correct and he wants
to promote a view even if on the panel
if there's an expert who can prove the
viewpoint of the producer wrong in the
post-prouction he can edit the portion
which he feels is going against his
view. So when you see a TV talk show you
have to keep in mind that what is the
integrity and the intention of the
producer and the moderator because if
you doubt the intention of the producer
and the moderator and the integrity what
you see finally on the television in the
TV talk show or the panel discussion can
be edited and there are many instances
we can give where we can prove that how
it can be done. For example, when you're
taking an interview and suppose someone
asked me that what are your views
regarding the policies of George Bush
and suppose if I reply that I do not
agree with the policies of George Bush
in the post-prouction you can easily
edit do not and it will sound in the
show I am saying I agree with the
policies of George Bush. Actually I said
I do not agree with the policies of
George Bush but on the show it will
appear that Zakin is saying by editing
do not I agree with the policies of
George Bush and if a person who's being
interviewed if he does not know the
background of the media and if he shown
his own interview he may think okay it
was a slip of the tongue he may think
okay by mistake I said I agree with the
policies of George Bush. So if you show
his own interview and if he does not
know how the post-prouction is done, he
will think it was a sip of the tongue.
Actually it wasn't a sip of the tongue.
So that is the reason the integrity of
the producer of the show and the
moderator is very important. And this
can even happen more in a panel
discussion where what can be done that
parts of the other panelists
can be shown along with the person who
you differ with and he can be made to
appear that he's agreeing with the view
of the producer of the moderator. So
therefore panel discussion is more
dangerous as compared to a plain TV
interview. So that's the reason I
personally prefer giving a public
lecture and a TV talk as compared to
appearing on a TV interview or a panel
discussion or TV talk show. But between
the three as I mentioned I prefer a TV
interview because there's less chances
of editing and even after you edit if
you have said everything correctly
there's less chance of manipulation.
But if the intention of the moderator or
the person who's the host who's taking
an interview or the intention of the
producer is evil, then there's little
chance that you can undo it. In a panel
discussion, the moderator has more
flexibility of putting down the person
he wants to put down and uplifting a
person who he wants to uplift. So a
panel discussion I personally
prefer being out of a panel discussion
unless I'm sure that the integrity of
the moderator and the person who's
conducting the show and the producer it
is honest and I believe in it. I
normally prefer staying out of panel
discussions.
Jazaka Dr. Zakir for explaining that
point. uh we understand this integrity
and intention are very vital for you but
we are ultimately human we may er in
this judgment ultimately it's Allah
subhana wa t'ala who is absolute in this
kind of understanding
Dr. Zakir
on how many non-Islamic Indian
television channels have you appeared on
for TV interviews, panel discussions or
TV talk shows and what is your
experience about these appearances?
As far as appearing on non-Muslim TV
channels for TV interviews, for TV talk
shows, the panel discussion, I have
attended more of the foreign ones,
foreign TV channels than Indian TV
channels. many times in UK, in South
Africa, in USA, in many countries in
different parts of the world. As far as
Indian TV channels are concerned,
as far as my memory goes, maybe I've
attended approximately five. I remember
the first one that I attended was a talk
show conducted by Faruk Shik and the
program was MD and the topic of that
program was BBI. You know that was the
first one I attended and the second one
that I remember is I had a panel
discussion. It was a live show done by
CNN IBN and I was in the Bombay studios
of CNN IBN and there were two panelists
from Delhi that was the second one and
third one as five memory goals was a TV
interview that was conducted by RK Baj
on the RKB show that's on Sahara channel
and the fourth one
again I think was the TV interview it
was a different type on walk the talk
by Shagar Gupta who the editor and chief
of Indian express on NDTV and the last
one recently just two weeks back
or rather three weeks back it was aired
two weeks back on the ND TV and the
program was we the people which was
conducted by Barcad and the topic was
Muslim identity. So these were the five
programs that memory goes
only five programs you appear down all
these years with thousands of lectures
on one side and only five programs
if you ask
you got an opportunity only for that
I have been asked hundreds of times
hundreds of times to appear for talk
shows and for panel discussions at least
few hundred by many channels you name
the channels you could say easily most
of the channels that have talk shows I
have been asked to appear on many of
them at least a few hundred at times but
personally knowing that because I
already do come on various other
satellite channels I don't want my views
to be changed or to be altered
because of that I know what the
background is and I personally I
personally
don't really think that most of the
shows that take place are with the true
intention of the topic because I doubt
that since for a normal man it's
different for me since I'm a man of the
media and I appear on various satellite
channels and peace TV alone
alhamdulillah has a viewership of more
than 100 million and that is absolutely
it's a direct view without the producer
of these public lectures or TV shows
without altering the view and I trust
the integrity of the other Muslim
channels that's the reason because I
know that they will not change my view
I've appeared several times on Muslim
channels because of that I take care
because I had very bad experiences in
these past few TV talk shows. So because
of bad experiences and when I speak to
other people who have been on the show
they too have that and I really agree
with you when you said that we cannot
actually judge one's integrity until we
have proof for the same. Now because I
have spoken with other people who have
been on the talk shows I'm talking about
those people who know the media. a
person who does not know the media and
if he goes on the talk show he'll not
know what goes behind the curtain.
So once the talk show is aired then you
can say and be sure what was the
integrity of the moderator and what was
the integrity of the producer.
for us as uh lay people to understand
how the TV talk shows and the interviews
present your viewpoint properly on the
positive side and uh manipulated on the
other side. uh can you relate to us your
experiences you know TV talk shows maybe
your first talk show with Faruk Shake in
brief
the first talk show I had I don't
remember the year exactly somewhere I
think close to the early part of the
2000 or late part of the 1990s
that was the first TV talk show I
attended in India and as I told you the
program's name was MD
and the topic of that show was Btoki
and that called a Christian to represent
their
They called a Hindu and they called
myself and they called an atheist. There
were about four or five people in the
panel and there was a audience like the
way we have here and they asked that how
should a woman be, how should she behave
and everyone gave their view even I give
their view and when I started speaking
and while I was convinced when I give a
reply but natural I give with reason and
logic. So at the end of the show the
answer that I gave most of the panelists
agreed with it. Initially they may have
differed but when I gave the reasoning
that's more important for a woman to
look after children look after the home
not that she can't work as long as work
is modest she can go and work and all
these things. So the show went off very
well and the moderator Faruk Shik he was
a gentleman and I was very happy that
the first show that I did on the Indian
television channel I was very happy fine
I gave the answer the audience
questioned me and they criticized me
they attacked me I gave the reply now
when I gave the reply the other audience
agreed with my reply that's what I'll do
normally in a live question answer
session they ask me a question I give a
reply and I'm giving equal opportunity
and far did a good job but The bombshell
came later on. A few days later on, I
got a call from the channel saying that
the program did not end the way the
producer wanted. So, we are going to
have a re-shoot. So, please wear the
same suit, same shirt, same tie, same
dress
and come for the show. We're having a
re-shoot. And when I got this message
from my manager, I said this is
nonsense. Program was fine. There's no
problem in it. So we told that surely we
won't be coming because we felt the
program went perfectly fine. So they had
the re-shoot in the same studio in the
same setup.
Maybe all the other panelists came but I
did not go.
Maybe most of the audience came. They
had a re-shoot and after a couple of
weeks they had that aired on the
television satellite channel. And the
best part of it was
when anyone sees the show
they are seeing me sitting there nodding
their head many a time to things which
they did not nod at. So what they did
they reshot the whole thing and they
changed the view though I did not go the
second time but when they telecast it on
air it was shown as though it was shot
once and Dr. Zakin was there and was
agreeing with the wrong things also. So
this shows that the integrity of the
producer was absolutely unjust.
I don't blame the moderator.
I mean Faruk I can't blame him. He's
being paid for his job. He did a good
job initially. What he did next, I don't
know. So I can't comment on that. But
the end of the story is that when it was
aired, it was made to look that Dr. Zak
fine I did speak and they showed
portions of my answers which suited them
more than the other part.
But when it was aired on the channel, it
was shown many a times that the views
that I did not agree with. I was shown
there as I agreed with it. So this is
what I mean by saying the integrity is
very important. So what I say that these
shows the producer and the moderator
they are doing it for the living. I'm
not giving a speech for my living. I'm
not here to speak about Islam for my
living. I don't take a single penny from
anyone. In fact, we give you know so
because it is a bread and butter. Many a
time the producer they make a show which
is liked more by the audience. They are
more bothered about making what will
sell more or will have a higher TRP
rather than to know what is the truth.
Same thing with the moderator. If the
moderator is commanded by the producer
and he chooses the moderator, the
moderator is saying it. Or if the
producer is neutral and the moderator
wants to change the show, the moderator
can change the show and the producer
doesn't bother. So therefore, both are
important. The moderator as well as the
person who's the producer. So the first
show I had went off very well. But the
end result because they reshot it. It
was a disaster.
But then you again trusted CNN, IBN for
another program.
That's right.
Experience on that.
That was after many years. I don't know
when I I think I gave it after maybe
seven eight years after I appeared for
the first show. I think it maybe 2007
I believe when I went for the CNN IBN
show
and your experience on that
there because it was a live panel
discussion and the issue I think was
something to do with Muslims I don't
remember the main topic of that it was
done by
Rajiv Sardis
Rajiv Sardisai and Rajiv Sardisai he was
sitting in Delhi and there were a few
panelists in Delhi one of them as my
memory goes was the MP
I forgot the name who the editor of the
Muslim India
Say shabuddin s shabudin correct s
shabudin was there and there were other
couple of people in Delhi and I was
alone in Bombay that too was not a good
experience because I was hardly allowed
to speak only twice
and when I said something it wasn't
heard there because the microphone is in
their hand so it was a live show I could
only speak when I was allowed to speak
normally in a panel discussion like when
I speak the microphone is on no one can
cut me but here I was in Bombay they
were in Delhi
And I was hearing from the headphone
which was through a mobile I think I
don't know so there were questions asked
though it was a live show it was a live
show the telecast live but because of
this problem that my microphone didn't
work until they pressed the button so
there too it was not a good experience
but because it was live it didn't do
much damage only thing that fine Dr.
Zakin and I didn't say much or wasn't
given opportunity since it was a live
show. It was been telecast live because
of that I felt that there wasn't much
damage except that I was not given
enough opportunity.
They say twice hurt third time shy but
then again you jumped into the ring. you
went in and you appeared on the Rashtra
Sahara's RKB show and its host you know
RK Baj most people believe he is usually
very critical about Muslims that's what
I understand why
the reason I jumped for the third time
was it was interview the first two the
first was a panel discussion or a talk
show with the live audience though we'll
telecast later on the second was a live
telecast
so both were bad experiences. The third
was a TV interview. Now, as I mentioned
earlier that in a TV interview,
less damage can be done but damage can
be done. So, initially I refused but
when I came to know it's a live telecast
then I thought fine the damage that can
be done is they cannot edit my speech.
So, because it was a live telecast and
whatever that I was saying in the
studios of Sahara it was going live. I
did not mind attending it even though it
was RKB and I should say that
though Mr. Abaj did ask questions and
try to promote a view which he knows
will create differences in the Muslim
audience and he did ask certain
questions but because it was live
overall the show was good because I
could answer what I wanted to answer and
there was no editing post show. So based
on that I went for the RKB show the
third time. And then last year
uh we had Shikhar Gupta the editor and
chief of Indian express interviewing you
on his very famous show walk the talk.
Was it because you were selected among
the 100 most powerful Indians by the
Indian express 100 most powerful Indians
that or is some other reasons you agreed
to go under the interview and what what
was the experience there? See normal my
answer when anyone wants to take my
interview fine as you ask me Indian
channels I appear these are the
exclusive TV interviews I'm talking
about there are many snippets I've given
to various other Indian channels which I
have to give earlier on ETV Udu and many
other snippets you know asking my view
on certain issues even that I have
stopped now because when I give an
answer for 5 minutes edited one minute
and show so beside these five I've been
on many other Indian channels but mainly
these are small comments on certain
issue taking place whether it be on
education for Muslims or whether such
topics coming to this why did I accept
the interview
especially because Shakhar Gupta puts
many a prime minister and top leaders of
the world in a very hot seat that's why
we asking you this special
so the first time when they asked me to
appear for the interview my answer was
no but then my colleagues and my friends
told you know that Shikhar Gupta walk
the talk is one of the best interviews
that is held in the country it has the
highest ERP and
because I don't watch much of the
channels though I'm a man of the media I
appear on TV channels but I personally
don't watch much of television I did not
know what was walk the talk until my
friends and my colleagues they told me
it is a very important interview
conducted it's one of the best in which
the editor in chief of Indian express
Gupta he conducts this interview and
he's a man of integrity and he normally
interviews presidents prime ministers
and celebrities to a very high and he's
a man who you can trust. But before I
conducted the interview, I saw to it
that I spoke to him. And one week before
he conducted the interview, he came from
Delhi and he spoke to me for more than
an hour. And when we interacted,
I asked him that after you record this
program which will be talk show while
walking walk the talk. I asked him that
will it be shown completely or will you
edit it? He said it will be unedited.
You can take from me my word that 99%
unedited. Maybe little bit here or there
if you have to you know fit in the time
duration. So he gave me the word that he
will not edit and you see to it that my
view is not altered. So because he gave
this word to me and I checked up his
background and I trusted my colleague. I
agreed for the interview which he came
to Bombay again from Delhi and we had
the talk on the Wii seaface where it was
again for approximately 1 hour with the
ads it was approximately 45 to 50
minutes and I believe it was the best
experience that I had with the Indian TV
channels and I trust that Mr. Mr.
Shakhar Gupta he's a man of his word and
when I saw the interview I was very
happy he did not edit anything he did
not change my view though the same
questions that were so challenging were
asked by him he gave me chance to
clarify I gave my point of view and
believe me he was a man of his word he
did not edit anything and he kept it as
it is and that's the reason I liked that
show and that show next day after it was
telecast for the first time it came as a
full page article
on all 21 or 22 editions of Indian
Express throughout India. So really that
was besides coming on the television
satellite channel it even came as an
article a full page article in all the
editions of Indian express.
It's really courageous and that's what
makes India in a one way very great you
know when you have courageous people
like Shaker Gupta presenting various
viewpoints for what they are whether
it's the Islamic viewpoint whether it's
the Mauist viewpoint whether it's a
communist and difference and we have to
really congratulate him on that before
we ask Dr. Zakir Knight himself about
the program, his comments, his
introspection.
I would like to present
the feelings, the comments, the analysis
from the hundreds of emails that we have
received mostly from the NDTV website
itself and many from the Facebook as
well as a few from the other websites.
before our audience.
Let us see how they feel about it. And
of course, we have amongst us a panel of
enlightened people on this topic
breaking the stereotype Muslim identity
and popular culture who have strong
opinions of this subject. Many brothers
here behind me, on my right, on my left.
Uh we'll take questions from them to get
their comments before we move on to the
session of Dr. Zakir Knight himself
giving his expert comments. I would
prefer
to verbet him
put forward before all of you and our
audience
the email comments verbet him without as
a moderator manipulating any of the
words they have written so that I'm not
charged of the uh critical comment. uh
maybe you cut and chopped off and didn't
give an adequate meaning. So kindly
excuse me if some of the spellings or
the sentence construction might not be
very appropriate but it's apt to the
situation that we present them as we
received them. I begin with short
comments which we received in large
quantities. Comments like from tahur
raza dr we are waiting for your sequel
jazak
from mansour give answers to all of that
questions in peace TV. I was upset to
see you in debate 1 hour is not enough
for that debate. We had uh in the
earlier instance itself a long comment
from one brother Imran Ali. I would uh
urge your patients to hear his comments
which I found very introspective.
The moment I heard Dr. Zakir Nike is
taking part in the NDTV talk.
We the people I made myself available to
see how this time Barkad is going to
sideline the arguments of a renown
personality.
Well, I forgot that there is a level of
dishonesty from her side using which she
can sideline just about anyone. As
expected, he was not given enough chance
to speak and the focus was completely on
Shah Ruk Khan of Bollywood. Not just
that, second person who got the chance
to speak more was Karan Johar. Dr. Zark
needs to understand that such shows are
meant to just punch each other's
arguments with a single liner. One
cannot try to explain big concepts in
just few seconds. Although his
statements were bold, huge and true, too
much of noise pollution sidelined them
to some extent. To top this, Barkadat as
expected did not give fair time to Dr.
Zakir Nik. This was clearly evident.
But hold on, that's Dr. Zakir Nike. He
just doesn't walk away without really
sparking a thought process in people's
mind, irrespective of how much time he's
given. And as I thought he did the same.
If you carefully observe his statements,
they tickled the brain of the viewers
who would later go and check its
authenticity.
He knew there were millions of people
watching the show, including viewers who
don't watch Peace TV. And he took this
as a golden opportunity to ignite the
spark of reinvestigating the 9/11
attack, which was the origin of this
entire concept of terrorism and Muslims
getting stereotyped. He clearly informed
there were 75 DVDs released of top
American analysts and professors who
proved that 9/11 was an inside job. He
also quoted two websites names before
Barkadat cut him off. He quoted http
911truth.org
and one Mosite name which slipped my
mind. People would surely go back and
check these and hence find out the truth
for themselves. So even though time
given to him was not fair, he completed
his job. He made the following
punchlines. There is nothing called
moderate or liberal Muslim. There is
only practicing Muslim, partially
practicing Muslim and non-practising
Muslims. It is a duty of a Muslim to
tell others about the truth of Islam.
Blaming Osama bin Ladin or Taliban to be
terrorists based on CNN and BBC virgins
is wrong and unfair. It is important to
give fair hearing to such allegations
and check the truth before blaming
someone to be a terrorist. The videos
shown are nothing but morphed which
generally the media is good at. 9/11 was
an inside job and cannot be performed by
Arabs. Physical
appearance,
beard, cap, etc. do not come under the
70 major sins of Islam. So there are
more important things over and above the
physical appearance in Islam. But to
follow complete Islam, physical look
also is important. These statements were
more than enough to make people think
twice about their stance.
Shah Ruk himself was carefully listening
to these arguments and looked impressed.
That's my observation.
Maybe I am wrong. Also, he boldly spoke
out the truth without fearing anyone.
Unlike others, his confidence showed his
trust on Allah and how he can go to any
limit to speak the truth without fearing
anything. Based on this email on the
website by Imran Ali, we had responses
which are interesting too of one or two
other brothers. Mustafa Hussein responds
may peace, mercy and blessings of
almighty Allah subhanaa tala be on all
of you. Today I happen to see the
program we the people in which all the
Bollywood people were there along with
brother Zakir
and I'm totally unhappy to tell that the
media once again played double
standards. Barcadat supposed to be a
generalist forgot the rights of time
allotment. Many questions asked to
Zakirbhai were given only maximum 30
seconds to answer whereas others were
given two to three minutes.
All the answers to the questions were
interrupted by others to cut down
brother Zakir's answers and get it out
of context.
Just see the double standards of the
media. I request all the people reading
this message to stand up and do the best
to stop this evil as there is a sai had
that whoever sees the evil around him
should stop with his hand. If not then
tongue if not at least by the heart.
This is the lowest level of iman.
According to me, these media people have
cheated Zakirbhai or else he wouldn't
have accepted those sort of rules.
However much people try to suppress
Islam, inshallah by the will of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, it will grow more
than that inshallah. This comment was
followed by another brother, brother
Navidid. He says, "Allah is always with
the truth. This media themselves show
that they were wrong and not true
people. As Allah said, truth stands out
clear from falsehood. Though brother
Zakir was not given chance but Allah
subhanaa tala showed the world through
their channel how patient he was and
peaceful to tolerate their injustice. If
Shah Ruk Khan and others want to lead
their lives according to their
perspective without following the rules
of Allah, they are at loss and not
realizing it now. But when the truth
will come in front of them, till that
time it will be very late for them to
tell now I want to be a practicing
Muslim. They may live a wealthy and
famous life in this world. But what will
be their fate after they die? not
thinking
maybe Allah gave haya to all humankind
to walk on the straight path and give
brother Zakiron more knowledge and power
to stand firm for Islam and protect him
always a mean all our prayers are with
him to this there's a response from a
true Indian Muslim that's how he calls
himself if anyone should be downcast out
there it should be Dr. Zakir. He
supposedly is a learned scholar and
knows the ins and outs of Islam. Or so
he says. He says Osama is not
responsible for the 9/11. He's spreading
a wrong word again and that's a bad move
as he has many followers. I'm sorry, but
I beg to defer on this. Websites,
journals, media might say what they
want, but a person's words can be
altered. What attire is Dr. Zaki dressed
in? Why does he pose for photos in a
suit? Why not wear the dress of the
Arabs when he proclaims to go all out on
Islam? Considering this man has so many
followers, he shouldn't spread a wrong
word saying Taliban, Osama, etc. wasn't
responsible for 9/11. That's absolutely
wrong. I don't go by what CNN, BBC or
any other biased channels have said, but
by the people themselves who have taken
ownership of what's happened. I don't
think anywhere in our religion has
something been mentioned as killing the
innocent to prove a point. In fact, no
religion teaches that. So again, I
wonder what these extremists were
playing at. The fact that he perceives
that Taliban and Osama aren't
responsible for 9/11 doesn't go down
well with the audience.
More judgments about Islam are made by
the general public thanks to this hero.
It is very easy for us to sit in one
safe country state and enjoy the
luxuries of living it up. Go try living
in Congo, Mozambi, Iraq, Zire, etc. The
extremists from other religions will
massacre you.
Extremism in any form and any religion
is nasty. It's an evil to society. It
should be suppressed. By doing anything
in excess, even a fruit of Jenna can
turn into poison. By writing this mail,
I didn't mean to hurt anyone's
sentiments. I'm sorry if I have.
Instead, I want to just reach out to all
of you in my own little way to tell you
that although I'm not a five times
namazi, I do have certain values in me
that I believe are in line with what
Islam preaches. I'm sure all of you are
far better biased and balanced Muslims
than me. I firmly believe that in my own
little way I will try to make people
change their wrong perception about
Islam by projecting Islam to be tolerant
humanity respecting religion. Cheers. I
and PS Barka or nobody else was being
biased. If anyone is biased, it is Dr.
Zakir. Come on, it's a freaking debate
where there will be differences of
opinion, not onetracked conversation.
Brothers and sisters, you would have
noticed we have had some positive
comments come critical. This was one of
the comments which was critical of the
earlier statements. I'm presenting the
various viewpoints in a balanced format
before all of you. So you appreciate the
kind of responses we are getting to the
program. Some positive, some neutral,
some critical.
Then we have a response to this email on
the same site by Saras Ali Khan. Wlaykum
salam to all who wished me and assalamu
alaykum for others to join later. This
is in response to true Indian Muslim
had said about the show. As my brother
has said, he doesn't have to go to the
CNN or BBC to check whether Osama
planned the 9/11 attacks.
If he did not see it on the media
channels, then where did he see it and
on which channel he saw that Osama took
ownership or which newspaper did he read
in? See, I'm not supporting Osama. If he
has done it, we condemn. But if he has
not then brother just on the basis of
suspicion 50,000 Afghanis were killed I
would like to ask you
have you seen lose change if you have
not then see it. This documentary has
not been done by any Muslim. It has been
done by an American. And you will see
that the Taliban speaking in English
though you might not understand Arabic.
They ask for a proof from the Americans
that Osama was behind it. And they said
if they provide it then they themselves
will hand over Osama. This telecast was
just shown once on the news channels and
after that it was never shown. Brother,
you said go to Iraq, Zire, Congo.
Brother, I would like to just wear the
Muslim attire and go to Assam. The Ulfa
is going to butcher you like anything.
They are specially trained to kill
Muslims. 749 confirmed attacks. Guess
what Zakir Nik did in his full attire?
Gave a public speech. Alhamdulillah.
This is the power of Islam to walk on
the way of Allah. If you are not doing
your duty, don't ask others to stop
doing dawa. I appreciate that you are
trying to teach others in your own sweet
way. But what about the rest who would
teach them this man runs a channel which
is viewed by over 70 million people? It
has outbeaten god TV. Brother, our job
is to deliver the message, not to
convert them so that on the judgment day
you can give the shahada that you
delivered his message to them. But at
least try and who knows you might open
the doors of heaven for someone and this
man has opened the doors to heaven for
hundreds of people. May Allah give peace
and show all of us the right path.
That was a long and interesting
discussion and comments on this article
initiated by Imran Ali.
We have brother Manoj Mishra a
non-Muslim who has given this
interesting comment. It's strange that a
person of Dr. Zakarunik's caliber and
fame an expert in the field of
comparative religion
is not given time to speak but instead
people like Su Ali Shah Rukh Khan and
lesserk known Kabir Khan is given all
the time to speak on issues which they
hardly know. Let the specialist of that
field speak out rather than noviceses of
the field. Yes, if Shaa or SRK or Kabir
Khan or Salman Khan speak about films,
it's okay. Though I am a Hindu and have
seen Dr. Zakir Knight speaking on peace
TV and debating live around the globe on
the various topics of comparative
religion and related issues. I can tell
you he is uncomparable. Barka by not
giving time to Dr. Nikk has done great
injustice to the stature of the person.
Dr. Nyik is Dr. Nikk Dr. Nyak should
never come to any TV debate where he's
not allowed to speak or express his
views. Thanks. Thanks. Humayan Kabir
says, "I have watched the videos. Dr.
Zakir Na should not have gone there.
Nobody was stopped before they finished
talking. But Dr. Ny was stopped every
time when he was about to finish his
explanation. If you ask an engineer to
help a cancer patient, what will happen?
I feel sorry for Dr. Zakir Nike. Again,
Allah helps us all. Sajad Ahungar says
it was ridiculous to listen to some
people who talked about things of which
they had no idea whatsoever and each one
tried to formulate a definition for
Islam just to fit his or her practicing
of the religion if they do any.
It was equally disgusting to see Barhan
never letting Dr. Zakir speak on
anything. He was the most knowledgeable
person on the podium but sadly made a
mute spectator.
We have a non-Muslim sister name is Ki
Mishra.
She says we the people is not
representative and totally undemocratic.
We means barka and a leftist friends who
show and talk their biased opinions and
a majority of the people's opinion is
sideline. What a mockery of neutral
journalism. We have another non-Muslim
brother Vijay
Lugani who says more we discuss about
minority communities more we create
problems for them. Everybody in our
country should feel equal to each other.
Nobody should be suspicious to each
other. If somebody does or act against
the law, the law should take its course.
SRK was best in discussion. Before I go
on with the further comments, I would
like to throw open the floor for
comments from our learned brothers, our
audience collected here today. We thank
you for your patient listening to these
uh long comments and initiation of
understanding of this topic TV talk
shows and analysis. May I request the
brothers would like to put forward their
comments first and later on any
question. We'll allow questions later on
to Dr. Zakir. I would like your comments
regarding the TV talk shows. Yes,
brother.
Well, my observation and comment on the
program of NDTV 24 by7 was that uh Dr.
Zakir Nayak was the only person out of
the eight speakers who did not interject
any speaker and all the others in the
panel continuously kept on interjecting.
The most out of them was uh Alec and
Kabir. In fact, Kabir interjected Dr.
Zakir at least three times. It was as
though he was asked to cut short
whenever he was about to speak. And if
you notice that Dr. Zakai kept raising
his hands for about more than 75% of the
time of the entire program and what was
shown on the TV was just that raising
once or maybe twice. So the program was
definitely edited over there. What I
would say is that Dr. Zakir Nayak was
the only person out there who was
following the rules of the program like
a true Muslim in spite of him being
sidelined for the entire program.
Thank you, Jazaka.